tornadoes lightning and hail are tearing
through the South
early Sunday multiple Twisters were
reported in Georgia and overnight
intense storms brought heavy rains and
flooding but it was Friday's tornado in
Mississippi that decimated the area and
left more than 25 people dead how aware
that the tornado was was could be in the
forecast
but I was not aware that it was coming
Gail Barfield and her husband Howard
heard on TV they had two minutes to take
cover when the tornado hit a wall
crashed onto the closet trapping Gail it
took a pickup truck to eventually free
her how are you still here God
you believe God saved you
know later that day her husband suffered
a heart attack he's now recovering in
the hospital the destruction is
widespread and in every direction with
at least 2 000 homes damaged or
destroyed from Friday's tornado